show you what's happening behind us we
saw a short while ago
uh a van turn up and a load of push
chairs
wheelchairs baby car seats uh were
given to the the volunteers here they
were all unwrapped they were all put up
and now they're all
being dispersed and given to the
families who are arriving there's a
family who just arrived here with a
little a little child in a blue baby
grow
um and the younger daughter
i think she's probably about 10 was
carrying the child presumably they must
have carried that child from wherever
they've left
in ukraine and they got here and they
came around the corner and they saw the
their own buggies and her eyes just lit
up and she's run up and and grabbed the
buggy
and uh i guess she's not carrying the
baby anymore after after a good few days
carrying a baby on a train uh she looks
pretty delighted um
so these are going so quickly they are
they are all being taken and they're all
incredibly welcome we're also seeing the
police here as you can see just passing
me helping people who are carrying uh
their belongings all of the people who
are arriving
at this station are being met by
volunteers they're being offered
whatever help they can
the problem of course is that and you
can see also wheelchairs also being
distributed behind me as well the
problem is that these people
presumably do not want a lot they they
can only take what they can carry and
they are probably carrying
as much as they can possibly manage so
to that end the volunteers are also
helping them carry their bags helping
escort them to the right train the right
platform so at least they can get away
from here without too much trauma